[Music]
hey what's up you guys I'm on the set at
night school and I can't wait me to meet
this crazy cast and hopefully I do
nothing to get suspended will Packer
told me that you pitched this idea to
him 4:00 in the morning at a club in
London you know sometimes you see a
group of people where it just looks like
a man that does look like a lot is on
their mind leave the character that
you're doing right now is this guy just
look like you got a lot on his mind he
pitched the idea to me of he and a group
of misfits a la Breakfast Club for
adults you know who have to go back and
get their GED within a certain period of
time by going to night school I was like
desperately I'm cooking back off with
Kevin saying you know it's like one trip
to juvie you don't stop the real dude
what you say is a superlative for you
for this cast oh I'm probably smarter
than everybody on this cast I am focused
on the school I ain't never been in
London but you know you know once my
probation is our best believe we'll get
there you're on tomorrow
read like this please the good thing
about this movie is that Kevin's not the
only play first minute and that gives
its own challenges to him because he
cracks up so I got a surprise for you
your first Apple as a teacher healthy
nutritious
I love sessile Tiffany Haddish right now
I feel like she's having this it-girl
moment as a comedian she's such a great
funny free spirit that you know an
amazing storyteller what's on my English
says I think we had to write a creative
story and so I had got that Garfield
book and changed all the name just
changed all the names just copied
everything got my daughter she was like
this was the best creative story only
other time did I remember seeing so much
magic come out of thin air
on a project was the first time I met
you or your version for your work that
cast in this cast every single day I'm
like people are just pulling magic out
of thin air
[Music]